i mean it's like the pulp fiction
suitcase is it just like glowing light
i don't remember what the box is what's
in the box
there was nothing you can't eat those
for like legal reasons i
i knew that that wasn't how it was gonna
end i mean it's gotta be good
okay all you
have to do is connect here's the biggest
question that i had
as i was watching the show when you're
popping the soma
what are you actually eating on a few
occasions
it's a tiny sort of plastic bead so if
you're ever really really close on them
they have that
sort of see-through-ness you can't eat
those
most of the time it was a um they were
cake
decoration it's like a little uh
jelly thing i guess it's very soft
there's the basic one which i think is
sugar that you
you want to crunch but i those got stuck
in my throat
and there's there are other ones which
are jelly which don't look good if you
touch them because they squish but those
can also
sit on your tongue and they can just
dissolve doing scenes and trying to
swallow them really quickly and if you
can't then just wash under your tongue
the whole time okay it's like quite a
technique to sort of
yeah get used to that different people
were a lot better at it than
i was you know uh harry and jessica i
think we're better at it by episode
three onwards when you see bernard
taking a pill if you don't see that pill
there was no pill
uh and just because it's alignment and i
i find it difficult i always want a
glass of water to swallow
where is everyone there's nothing here
in the brave new world the novel by the
end of it
bernard and helm get banished but
at the end of season one it almost seems
like they're exiling themselves
break it down for the fans out there
what is happening good point
yes they have exiled themselves a lot
happens in that final episode
i would watch it again i did and i i i
i got even more out of it so helm and
bernard have kind of come together
potentially
it seems i know this is i don't know
this this is my theory
the indra has kind of manipulated this
because she needs a new host she needs a
new society
this is why i think and so that she has
gotten to burn its brain took him to
that red room at the point where the ten
commanders what are they called mustafa
and her crew are being switched off
she's got to go right then and there
sabonita accepts that and he is her host
in that moment
wakes up on the cliff helms separately
through looking at john's memory
has seen a glimpse of indra and realizes
that indra looks like mustafa as a young
woman and is also given a vision of
bernard on this cliff surrounded by
people
some kind of leader it seems so she's
drawn to bernard and for different
reasons they go to the savage lands with
this box which
you assume contain some kind of intro
but no one knows
i saw david the other night he literally
stole no
what's in the box what is in the box i
think
do you know i do not i don't for sure i
i again i've got my theory it's pretty
basic
i look forward to finding out i don't
remember what the box is
do you know what's in the box i don't i
really don't and it's
because i was sitting and watching
episode nine
with my partner and we were both
screaming at our tv what's in the box i
mean it's like the pub fiction suitcase
is it just like glowing lion
uh yeah is it like a wi-fi router you
know the indra is just this is her kind
of
it's just the hardware you need to set
up the network i don't know
i mean it's got to be good because she
suddenly goes from saying i told you to
never come back here
to you know giving them a lift so yeah i
don't know it's got to be
i don't know what it is what is it i get
i have no idea what it is
but um yeah i i want to find out
if you're not happy or nothing at all
book lovers
actually realize that there's going to
be quite a bit of a change
between the ending of season one and the
ending of brave new world the book
in the book john actually commits
suicide were you expecting to see that
in that final script you know for like
legal reasons i
i knew that that wasn't how it was gonna
end i just think like
the emotions and the ideas that are in
the book
they found these really interesting
different adaptations for
to convey those through a series and and
bring it into our world
when we last seen john he is in kind of
a
dilapidated apartment and for a second
we think that he
is with his lady love and then it seems
like she's not quite there can you break
it down for us
yeah it's somewhat uh i think it's like
some of it's mysterious but
yeah you see him with lunina and then
you realize that she
that he's like doing a sprite which is
in the series you can like conjure
the image of somebody who's not
necessarily there and i think it's a
really interesting place for it to end
on you're in this
this totally different world like where
am i and something is brewing there's a
change
you know that i think could lead to some
really cool stuff
lina we see her somewhere far away
where is she when we say goodbye to her
i have no
idea because this is kind of wild we
sort of
it just wasn't necessarily part of
something that was in the script
it's something that we've found later on
um lanina's story was gonna end
slightly earlier and i guess seeing her
first with john
and then realizing and for a moment i
think when i watched it
i was thinking oh yay and then you see
this flicker in her face and you realize
she's not there he's sort of seeing her
but she's not in that room
and then seeing her far away i've no
idea where she is
i always thought she was gonna get out
of new london she was one of the most
enthusiastic to do it
so i wonder where she is i have i have
no idea i actually don't know
so i'm really excited at the prospect of
possibly being able to find out were you
surprised that they didn't end up
together just kind of like the two of
them versus the world
i was surprised i thought it was a
really interesting move i also think
there was a version where
they did and then you know this this
took it in a different direction that's
what i love about the show
is that every time something happens it
always becomes
the most complicated human messy version
of it
you know so there are no easy answers to
these questions
the show is asking a lot of questions
but it's all about
what it feels like to be a human being
in the midst
of a complicated world i love that she
is
independently standing there i think
it's sort of something that at the
beginning she's so desperate for
connection
on a deeper level but she's convinced
that means she has to connect with
someone
and i think she goes on a huge journey
and discovers that in fact the biggest
stranger who she does not
truly understand is herself and that
and the only way she's going to be able
to
survive or truly explore the world
and her position within it is by
being with herself and so i think i mean
that speaks to me
definitely so i thought i thought it was
an amazing space to see
to see her get to by the end of the yeah
the show
what do you know about season two if we
do get one
literally uh nothing i cannot tell you a
single thing
i had dinner with david uh last week
and he says that he doesn't know and he
does and but he
he just i think right now he needs a bit
of a holiday once this is out
is there anything that you would like to
personally see anything that you're
pushing for season two or any questions
you would like to have answered
yeah i guess i would be curious to see
what happened if uh first of all i wanna
know
what does a savage lens look like in the
month or two since we've seen it is
there just
anarchy now that there's no barrier have
they spread out does it is it a kind of
wild west situation
do we have optic interfaces do we
subjugate them to what does sheila want
do we want to raid an attack on new
london would bernie be interested in
that
but my main question is what does indra
want what is she going to do differently
with this society the last one she just
had to kill it because humans cannot be
stable
she's dealing with humans again what's
changed what does she want
there's a really interesting thing to
come up at the end of
season one you know especially for my
character
there's a whole different understanding
of what
kind of him realizing his what he's
accountable for
and responsible for and i think i'm
excited to see
what he does next with that knowledge if
season two were to go again
if it were to happen i have the thing
about the show is that it sort of could
go anywhere
and i don't even know where lanina is at
the end
so i want to find out so
much what she up to uh yeah so i have no
idea
but if we don't find out what's in that
box during season two and
i don't know what we're gonna do and we
are just done
i'm done unplug us from intro we're out